Police say they know who's behind a string of weekend paintball
gun attacks that left several people hurt. >> Okay, this
is 3 days ago. We'll go from the beginning. Zena was on the run.
She was on the lamb for a little bit running from Johnny Law.
Okay, I get people like clown Darius, but Zena was like she's
kind of like in tears and emotional. I'm like she he would have
muted if she was like in a bad place. I don't know. >> Wait,
for what? >> Hold up. >> No, I can't. You're on stream.
I really can't. Icy said the phone is not letting her answer.
>> Bro, I need to get a hold of her. Can I get the point
I needed on you? >> She said every time that you call,
you're she's trying to accept and it's not letting her accept
and it hangs up on her. >> Well, just just answer. Wait
a second. Just answer the question. >> I know he didn't
use condoms and I kept trying to find out. >> Why wasn't
Okay. Why is he upset though? >> At the time and I was
like, "Okay, whatever." Why is he upset though? He cla because
>> All right, let's move on to the Zena stuff. So, Zena
got arrested for the paintball gun, right? The paintball gun
at these people. Let's uh let's go back and take a look. All
right, we're we're going to switch switching gears over to the
Zena stuff.
Let's flipping go. Let's go. Where do I got it here? I got it
over in the Discord.
Boop
boop.
Here we go.
The day six recap recap for scavenger hunt. I think it is largely
going to be the Zena stuff,
I I
do not care about this.
>> We got through the fight stuff and we did not get through.
So after the fight. >> All right, I'll give it to him.
>> This is uh this is after the fight is where we get the
Zena stuff. Okay.
>> Can we watch the fight?
>> What? What are you guys asking about?
This is the news report. Yeah, we're going to go through it.
>> Take the keyboard off. >> Don't worry. We'll go
through it. >> Put that down. >> Oh, no. I mean,
drive. Oh, no. >> Oh, hold on. This is actually too early.
Okay, hold on. There was also
So, after Zena was uh was caught. Okay, we had this not caught
before Zena was caught. >> They say they know who's behind
a string of weekend paintball gun attacks that left several people
hurt. >> It happened around Lakeshore Boulevard near Ladyberg
Lake. Kview View's Jessica Cha breaks down what happened. >> Some
go to lake. >> This is three days ago. Okay, this is three
days ago. We'll go from the beginning. Zena was on the run. She
was on the lamb for a little bit running from Johnny Law. Okay.
>> Lake for the trails or for the calm
>> You come here to enjoy the lake and like the scenery,
not to get shot by the >> On Saturday, Austin police say
someone reported they had been shot by a paintball gun earlier
in the day. Police believe multiple live streamers armed with
paintball guns were participating in a scavenger hunt along Lakeshore
>> Where did she
do you know who it was? >> As all of this played out, the
people who were part of this were filming on cameras and streaming
it live online. >> She just got shot in the thigh by one
of >> In the clip, you can hear one of them say another
group of streamers shot someone who was at the epic sub paddle
board and rental kayak business along Ladybird Lake. >> Yeah.
So, somebody got shot. I think one of the other people who got
shot is Adriana probably and probably Squeeze, right? So, those
people wouldn't be pressing charges. They'd be like, "Whatever
is a part of the game or >> I'm paintballing before you
guys
and it's still a little painful with that." >> Steven Hernandez,
who rides his bike along Ladybird Lake every so often, says things
like that make him hesitant to come back. Maya Gdowski says it's
not going to stop her, but that does make her angry. I I feel
like this day and age where social media can really make you
or break you. People are feels like going out of their way to
just try to be funny when they're they're not. They're just disrespectful.
>> Austin police say they have identified a suspect, but
they haven't been able to arrest that person yet. In downtown
Austin, Jessica Cha, KV News. >> Okay, so this is 3 days
ago in the morning. This came out. Okay.
3 days ago in the morning on the 12th,
Zena decided to go out and continue to help her friends in the
scavenger hunt off stream even though she was banned. Okay, this
is also 3 days ago. This is Icy stream if it will load.
Please kick, don't do this. Okay. Uh, need a new tab that's not
crashing.
Please just work for the love of God. Okay. Okay. Uh, this is
[__] cooked. Okay, here we go. Finally. And it's
muted. And it's crashed. And it's kick.
I [__] love kick. I love kick. I love kick. I love
kick. I love kick. I love kick. I love kick. So awesome when
kick just totally the bed like this. It happens so often. Thank
you. Okay. Jesus
>> She's not on stream. >> She said this is the show.
>> Like her voice could be in the background. You guys
are You guys have been trying to troll me all day because you
hear Zena's voice in the background, but she's not the focus
on my stream. She's My stream is on my face as I'm >> Like,
what are we talking about here? What are we talking about? And
you guys just made me miss the turn. >> So So she's helping
Icy. She's out with Icy.
Okay. And then eventually she gets pulled over. All right. Or
sorry, eventually I believe Shuy gets pulled over, right? Shuy's
here whenever the arrest happens. Let's watch from Shu's POV
here. What's going on? >> I don't I don't mean it sound
insensitive, but could we like crash to her house tonight?
>> Nah, I have no way of getting in. But no, that no >> money
on hotels.
>> No, that's crazy. Wow, that's >> Let me go back.
>> What? That was
>> Take your seat belt off. Put that down. >> Oh,
what?
>> is Zena the camera? Is Zena Zena's filming? Yes, Zena
is filming right now. out of a license plate light on your rear
uh license plate. >> Hey, back up. >> Get out of
the road. >> Get out of the road. >> We were unaware
of that. >> Unaware of what? >> We were unaware that
was working. >> Hold up. Put that down. >> Okay,
so this is where Zena does get >> Yeah, don't hit
>> Yes, Zena is banned from kicking filming with an active
warrant two days ago.
All righty.
>> Uh, this is her phone.
>> I'm going to open this so she can point out stuff. Okay.
>> Can you open this so she can point out?
>> Oh, little context here. Little context.
Little context for the guy who's the victim today. Okay. >> Make
him hesitant to come back. Maya Gdowski says it's not going to
stop her, but that does make her angry. I I feel like this day
and age where social
>> imagine you see this news article and then you went
out to the domain later that day and you saw the same guy in
the news article wearing a pink bikini with a selfie stick. Like
you see it's like oh you just watch the news and then all of
a sudden later that day you see him walking around in a pink
bikini. >> Age where social media can really make you or
break you. People are feels like going out of their way to just
try to be funny when they're they're not. They're just disrespectful.
>> Austin police say they have identified a suspect, but
they haven't been able to arrest that person yet. In downtown
Austin, Jessica Cha. >> Well, if they download my app,
if the police download my app, they will see her [__]
location cuz I'm pretty
The police had the app, by the way. That's very likely how they
found her. Ice knows that, doesn't he? I thought I watched a
clip before earlier in the scavenger hunt where ICE explicitly
said the cop showed up the first day. They downloaded the app.
I said that was fine and they would know where everybody was.
I'm almost positive. Anyway, we got we still got the shuvy thing
here. Let me look at ISIS POV real quick. >> I mean Oh
no.
>> Isis POV. The same situation. >> Oh, they know
they know who she is. They know her, bro. I mean, that's risky
business, man.
>> Oh, dude. That's risky business. >> She didn't
do nothing wrong.
>> She ain't do [__] >> I mean, when
you have a warrant out for your arrest, it's real risky to be
hanging around on stream.
>> She did nothing wrong.
>> Turns out she unfortunately did exactly what she got
arrested for. >> Did Shuy get got for that stolen van?
No, I think he actually got the van registered. He got a plate
for it and probably was fine.
>> I mean, and Shuy Shuy caused it as well. because he
got no tags on his car. So, they pulled the van over.
>> I think he's got tags on his car. I think it's that
he didn't have a backlight, like a back end light for the license
plate that was out >> because he got no tags and then they
saw her and then once they saw her, it's game over.
>> I wonder I mean, Shu is going to get a massive ticket,
dude. >> Driving around with no plates is like a I don't
even know, maybe $500 ticket, $1,000 ticket.
by the car. They'll shoot you. >> Get out of the road.
If I have to tell y'all the game, you will go to jail. Stay out
of the roadway.
>> They're not playing around. Said he had no registration
or or tags on his car. So, I mean, I I saw this coming from a
mile away. I I knew this was going to >> Like, if you're
being investigated by the police and you have a warrant,
>> what? Like, obviously, this was bound to happen at some
point. probably shouldn't be out streaming with people, right?
>> Seems like that makes the most sense. >> You need
to do anything, Zena. Zena, do you need a lawyer or something?
>> Do you need a lawyer? >> I have a lawyer. >> Okay,
you're all good.
>> Everyone on the sidewalk. Everyone on >> I have
a lawyer. Well, she might have a lawyer. I think she she ends
up asking a couple people for bail. Now, here's the article.
Okay, I think we got a video as well. We could watch this video.
A live streamer who police believe shot random people with a
paintball gun is now facing two misdemeanor charges. Austin police
arrested 29-year-old Amiris Samson yesterday. Investigators say
she shot someone with a paintball gun while participating in
a scavenger hunt with two other streamers along Lakeshore >> Cape
live streamer. >> All right, let's just watch the >> witch.
I'm lazy. Let's just watch.
Unfortunately for me or not unfortunately Just Zena's name's
been said so many times. I'm not really that concerned about
it being said to be honest with you. Uh >> time after she
was caught using a paintball gun to a random person at Ladybird
Lake. Fox 7 Austin >> like once I'm watching news articles
about her getting charged. I don't know that it's like it's just
not the same thing. Right. >> Olivia Pharaoh has the >> they
got her name. Oh
yeah.
Oh man. Maybe I should go cover that. Destiny Willy review or
whatever. I could just point out the thing with my logs from
Destiny's chat when I talked to him. Um that I can tell you exactly
what happened with that solo guy. That solo guy basically had
never posted in uh Queen's Discord, right? He he posted like
maybe once before or something. I don't think he'd been there
for like a super long time. And then he dumped only
screenshots of text with Lauren Southern and that's the only
thing he shared with anyone else. It's the only thing he shared
with Sunday. There was no like the I don't think there was almost
any conversations just with the the Rose person even. It was
like all of Destiny's conversations that he shared with Lauren
Southern that he shared with this girl of like him talking to
Lauren Southern. Oh, I watched uh I watched what do you call
it? Destiny reviewing the Willie Mac video and he pulled up some
logs to show that like the solo guy was a big Queen fan and it's
like no, that's not even the case. Um the guy dumped it in Queenman's
Discord originally. Quan said he wasn't going to run with it.
Didn't run with it. deleted all the messages and then I think
eventually banned the guy. He might not have banned the guy right
away. Wait, wait, wait, wait. He deleted all the messages though.
Deleted all the leaks and said like, "I'm not running with this."
Lee Mack is sprinting to make a tweet about your doxing here,
JC. Probably. I don't know. I could maybe I'll go through it
later, but um like that that would all be easily provable.
Um yeah, the only thing about Queen's video I didn't like is
that it felt disorganized. Okay.
Um,
yeah, the Destiny totally misrepresents the solo thing. I only
told Destiny the stuff that was relevant to him was that like,
hey, this getting leaked. Um, I felt really bad for the guy,
right? You can tell I feel really bad for the guy in the logs
he leaked. Like, man, this is really up. There's like uh like
conversations with this person. It's pretty gross. >> Latest
on her arrest.
>> No nudes in any of that though. No nudes. The only reason
I knew that there was videos in there potentially was Destiny
told me that hey that I sent that person videos of me sucking.
So I hope they don't leak anything more. That's uh that's how
I knew there were videos in there.
But that the no the videos leaked originally. The person didn't
leak any to Queen. He didn't leak any to Sunday.
But Desi told me that he sent this person videos of him sucking.
29-year-old Ammeris Samson, more commonly known by her kick username
Zena the Witch, was arrested Wednesday night around 10 p.m. She
was arrested for intentionally causing bodily injury and deadly
conduct. On Saturday, August 9th, Samson is seen in a live stream
of a random person with a paintball on the trail near Ladybird
Lake. She's participating in an annual citywide $30,000
prize moneyw worth scavenger hunt that's hosted by another streamer,
Ice Poseidon, but the event is not city sanctioned. Austin police
were searching for Samson as she >> I said it was. Apparently
Zena >> for her arrest. They located Zena. >> The
news is saying it's not. I assume the news checked with the cops.
The witch while live streaming with other streamers in a van
with no license plates outside >> Oh, ICE pointed out it
didn't need to be sanctioned. Okay. All right. >> Fox 7
Austin on East 10th Street. The arrest caused quite a streamer
frenzy where many of them showed up and streamed the arrest.
In an expost, Ice Poseidon is seen >> I just got a permit
for the first meetup spot. That's it. Ah.
Ah. punting on the situation, saying, quote, "I saw this coming
from a mile away. I knew this was going to happen. If you are
being investigated by the police with a warrant, obviously this
was bound to happen at some point." Zena the witch is >> That's
kind of a misquote, right? It makes it sound like he was saying,
"Oh, obviously someone's going to get shot with a paintball gun."
When he's saying, "Obviously, if Zena goes out with a warrant
on a stream, she's going to get arrested." That's uh that's like
a total total misquote. That's like weird how they just use that
>> official kick account has been banned and shut down.
>> What a mugsh shot. Why? What do you mean what a mug
shot? It's a pretty good mug
>> She could face up to several years in prison and a $10,000
fine. Libby Farrell, Fox 7 Austin News.
>> Ah, see this is a this says random person. She's a random
person on the trail. That ain't a random person, mother. What
do you think they're holding? That's a selfie stick. That's Adriana
Lee.
That's not a random person. That's not the person who got shot.
>> Years in prison and a $10,000 fine. Libby Faroh, Fox
7 Austin News. >> If convicted, Samson could be fined up
to $10,000 and serve several years in >> Up to one year
in prison, it looks like although I guess she's got multiple
class A misdemeanor, so maybe the maybe another one goes another
year in prison or something.
>> that was Adri.
Nick Fent has body cam
Oh, this is him. Hey, come on, man. And I'm a Mexican. My name
is Fentes. >> Uh or something.
>> You think you're you're a white >> I'm not a white
supremacist.
>> I know. I kind of white. >> Sorry. It hits Well,
it hits good every time. I don't know why this auto played, but
uh they say you're a white supremacist. Not a white supremacist.
I'm Mexican. My last name's Fentes. Okay. All right. So, I don't
know how much of this should be POV. It's like Zena getting arrested,
right? >> Yeah. Appreciate that. >> You got your
driver license. You got insurance on the car, too? >> Yeah.
So, >> just don't grab the knife, bro. >> Yeah. No,
you're good. You can move it if you want. >> No, no, no.
Just go. >> Yeah. It's for eating. I was using it to eat
the spam.
>> Yeah. Uh, my wallet's in the >> Hi, Officer. The
passenger is a wanted felon for assault. She's the streamer the
news was talking about. Amara Samson, check her out. She is a
career
>> I think they pretty clearly knew like they're they're
cuffing her already,
Really? Okay.
>> There's no way. >> Can you pass? >> There's
no way this stream There's no way that TTS got her. >> Get
your bag in just a minute. We can get your bag in just a minute.
>> It's right here. The black one. >> I'll get in
just a minute. Give it to >> Yeah. And now has my wallet.
>> Yeah, that's fine. >> Oh god, there's a paintball
gun. >> There's a rainbow. Okay, just leave it >> I
don't have any
>> Damn, bro. >> Hey, stay in the car. Stay in the
car. You're dained, too. >> Oh, sorry, sir. >> Stop
the car. They'll shoot you. >> Get out of the road. If
I have to tell y'all again, you will go to jail. Yeah, that's
called interfering with
>> that was playing
>> D10. D10's farming and playing music. Okay, what the
[__]
>> That's not funny, D10. >> But not everyone. >> Okay,
they grab Zena. There's Shivy there. Was I going to do more of
the Shuy stuff? I'm not sure that I care all that much about
um I don't know that I care all that much about anything but
Shuy talking to her after the fact. So, let's check this out.
I believe this is gonna be Shivy's call with her after the fact,
right? Oh, hold on.
>> Oh, wait a second. Hold the [__] up.
>> Oh no. Oh no. Zena's cooked.
>> Oh my god. 100. Oh no, she's cooked. Oh my god, she's
actually cooked.
>> And that's only one bond, bro.
>> I think the reason this bond is so high is because they
probably need to reach out to the other county or whatever to
make sure that it's not something massive, right? I don't think
this is like the standard. I don't think once they figure out
what this is, I think they set a lower bond, but it's like this
could actually be something really bad. We haven't like figured
it out yet, right? Okay. Hold on. Sorry, I'm a little I'm a little
discombobulated on this stuff cuz I didn't I didn't put it together
quite so well today. Okay. 13830. Well, that's not going to be
it. I Yeah, I don't think that's going to be it. Sorry. Hold
on. Maybe this is just everything we need, basically. So, Zena
did go to jail. Okay, she went to jail. And I'm just looking
for the shoe calls when she calls him after. Okay, this is him
calling after the fact. Oh, she's calling. It should immediately
connect if there's money on my account.
>> Press to refuse.
>> Oh, it's a free call. >> This call is from a rescue
facility and
>> Thank you for using
>> Hello. Yeah, I'm live. No, I wasn't
>> Dude, there's no way with this audio, right? Could we
get How does Chuvie not pay one of these with him to watch the
stream while he streams? Just get one person to go watch your
stream while you >> Why? I mean, I don't really want to
>> He farming. >> Can you text him right now?
>> Can I text Icy?
>> Yes, cuz I'm trying to get a hold. >> Bro, I don't
know why the every time you call it sounds so quiet.
But that sounds quiet. Can you please
>> Okay, hold on. Let me try to connect you to your speaker.
What do you want me to text? Icy.
>> I'm trying to get >> Okay. All right. I can text
her that >> you have to do a what to the what? >> I
can't say you're on the street. >> All right.
>> Why didn't everybody tell me? >> Sorry. What did
they say to you? >> Oh, no. I didn't get arrested. I got
And then with nobody picking up, I I decided what to do here.
>> Yeah. Well, I thought I was going to get
Hello. Who this? Really? What's up? How's it going? >> Um,
some [__] I'm talking on my >> Yeah, it's Holy.
It's trash. It's completely trash. Why? Why you on your phone,
bro? What's going on, >> dude? I'm I'm putting clothes
up and [__] dude. I'm I'm doing stuff. I can't get
on my computer. I can't get on my >> Okay. Okay. All right.
Sorry, that was like not listenable.
I think he said he's getting on his
Jesus.
Uh, this makes me feel bad cuz like I Say what you will about
Darius. I feel like Darius would mute here. Okay, so say what
you will about him, but he would mute. He wouldn't do this kind
of What's up, Brley? How's it going? Now your mic is muted or
something's going on. I'm not getting any sound. And I saw the
green go on, but I can't hear your mic. You hear me now? >> Yeah,
I can hear you now. There you go. >> Oh, okay. Cool. Uh,
what's the drama now? What's up? What's the update? >> I'm
going over Zena. Zena's uh calling Shuy from the where from the
jail. And I was just saying that uh she was like, "Can you mute?
I need to talk about some stuff." And then he was like, "No,
I don't really want to mute right now." And I'm like, "Bro, I
I get people like Clown Darius, but Zena was like she's kind
of like in tears and emotional." I'm like, she he would have
muted if she was like in a bad place. I don't know. She just
kind of like laughed and was like, "No, I'm not going to mute
right now." Feels kind of weird,
you know? >> I don't know. I How did Zena
Did Zena [__] over Shuy or something? I don't know
what their history is. >> No, I don't think so. Didn't
really [__] them over. I guess kind of [__]
over a little bit, but he's also >> he's also a little
whatever. He doesn't understand the seriousness of the
>> Yeah. Zena, did you see Zena's charges and [__]
>> No. What happened?
>> She got charged with deadly conduct for firing a paintball
gun into a crowd of people and hitting a cassid.
>> Oh, but it's a misdemeanor. >> It's likely the
misdemeanor misdemeanor. >> I don't know what class A means.
Is that the worst type of misdemeanor? >> I don't know.
Yeah. Well, it's up to a year in prison, so Or up to a year in
jail. Not Not prison, I guess. >> Oh,
Jesus Christ. And she's a If they're allowed to take into the
context the prior offenses, that's not looking good,
>> Yeah. Somebody is saying that this is
>> that the person she shot was like the daughter of the
governor. But I I don't know. They might also think that um she
was just shooting like a lot of random people or something cuz
like the news reported it and there are tweets of people saying
she shot a random person and the random person she shot was Adriana
Lee who was like while she was probably she got shot with a paintball
gun wouldn't have pressed charges or wouldn't have been like
it would have been like no I totally like not somebody who doesn't
want to be shot at basically >> Yeah. So they're cool with
her for sure. >> Yeah. It's like a little different. So,
wait. So, allegedly it's the governor's daughter. Allegedly,
you It's not
>> Well, I haven't seen anything. I don't know how you
confirm it, right? Here, let me uh let me pull this up. Like
>> I mean, Governor is pretty public person. I mean,
>> yeah. So, sorry.
What do you mean the governor is a pretty public person? What
does that mean? >> I mean, they're a pretty public person,
so I mean, there's a fair chance that some people are going to
probably know who their kids are, right? >> Uh, yeah. But
it was a it was a friend of her kid or a friend of their kid.
Sorry. It must be >> Oh, I thought you said I'm sorry.
I thought you said it was literally the governor's do. I thought
it was Greg Abbott's daughter. >> A friend of the governor's
daughter. >> Okay. My bad. >> Yeah. Yeah. But I don't
know, man. It's uh
Yeah. I I think she's kind of getting railroaded a little bit.
I could see her getting trouble, but like
I don't know. Getting going to prison for this seems kind of
crazy. I feel like she should face some consequences. She should
have to pay a fine. She should probably have to do some community
service or something. Whether they like get that done in Miami
or in Austin, I have no idea. But >> I don't think she
should have to go to prison for this. That's kind of crazy to
me. But this the the news was saying that this is a random person.
I'm just going to play this clip. Oh, wait. Go >> Yeah.
Um, no. Go ahead. Go ahead. >> Adriana.
So, I think this right there where she just fired those eight
shots, that's where she ends up hitting like a customer of this
place that isn't one of the streamers, but you don't see it.
You only see the aftermath where they actually got shot.
>> you're going to say something else here. What's up?
>> Um,
how Okay. So, do do we know if she intentionally shot a random
person or if it was accidental?
>> Deadly deadly conduct is reckless. So, uh recklessly
engages in conduct that places imminent danger of serious bodily
injury. So, this is likely what she's >> Serious serious
bodily injury.
>> Well, like >> I feel the only serious bodily injury
that can come from paintballing is like hitting in the eye, right?
>> Yeah. But you can and when you're firing into a crowd
of people, it's like hard to know if you would, right? Like it's
pretty bad. It's pretty bad if you just
>> Yeah. No, I I don't disagree. But deadly conduct, I
just don't I don't know. I feel like I I'm not sure like I would
have to think about like other scenarios like if you threw a
bottle in public at uh a crowd, would that count as deadly conduct?
Because in theory, you could cause serious bodily injury with
that. Um if you
uh I don't know,
like I feel like there's so many different things that could
meet deadly conduct that I'm not sure if I would be not sure
how I would feel about it. >> Yeah. I also wonder if like
fact-wise if they're taking into account that like she shot multiple
people but they're including like Squeeze and Adriana in that
where they were like kind of opting in like if it was just one
person would they have charged with this full >> I imagine
>> I imagine there's I don't know but I I imagine any like
because I'm going to this will have a jury right if it goes to
like it'll have a jury unless she just like pleads guilty to
this um I think right u but if it does I imagine that they could
probably be swayed by at least to some degree that she wasn't
just totally indiscriminately doing it to literally everybody,
but that >> there was, you know, a whole thing going
>> She'll plead this out like based on the facts, too.
Like, I'm I'm almost positive she pleads us down to no jail time.
Like, realistically, she's like a she does have a history, but
she's like a somewhat productive citizen, right? Like, she pays
>> she she makes money. She she inputs into the economy.
Like, she's not like a total deadbeat. And
I don't know. I just I feel like there's >> I feel like
there's a lot of reasons to just let her go to like Yeah. Let
her just walk and keep track of her for a while so if she does
something else she goes back for longer. Although one of the
things she's being held with is out of county misdemeanor. And
if this is for her beating on MC and they they view that at the
same time and it's like oh all the stuff's happening around live
streaming. I wonder if they don't go oh we're not going to plead
this out.
>> Like I wonder if they don't go yeah I think you actually
have to be in jail for a little while. $100,000
bond $100,000.
>> Yeah. I So I don't know for sure,
but I I think that this has to do with the fact that it's misdemeanor
undetermined as in out of county misdemeanor. Like we don't have
like a way to translate this or we don't know what it is. So
we're actually not we're not going to put something here that
makes sense. Like I I think >> you think that's like a
place they just Yeah, I think there's a placeholder basically.
That seems most likely to me.
>> All right. Be insane. >> Yeah. 100k. That'd be
crazy, bro. It seems like whatever the case is, assault causing
bodily injury seems to be a higher like a higher crime, right?
$4,000 bond versus a $2,000 bond.
Maybe deadly conduct is just like a silly name for something
that actually >> like spans a a broad base of possible
things. They give me shooty clips. I'm probably going to go in
order here. >> When I see deadly conduct, yeah, when I
see deadly conduct, I think it's serious business, but it seems
like it might not >> Dude, what the [__] is
this? What did I just get linked? >> All right, can you
can you put on your
>> Hold on. I need to show them this. Yo, I'm not trying
to be federal, but
>> you don't want to get >> Oh, it's a shirt.
>> Wait, hold on. >> Did he just lick his finger?
>> I don't know. But is this indicating that they hit another
random person? Icy had pink bullets. Zeno was using pink paintballs.
Faith Faithless Follower. Manic Inc. getting on the same team.
This is a different instance. Were they other people after they
walked away with the warn out? They shot more people with paintballs.
This guy's been shot multiple times. >> All right. Can
you Can you put it on your finger?
>> Hold on. I need to show them this. >> Yo, I'm
not trying. >> Oh, that's Chy's driver. Oh. Oh, >> be
federal. >> Never mind.
>> concluding. I didn't I said why?
It looks like they shot another person. What do you mean concluding?
Yeah, I concluded they shot another person. Where's the false
conclusion, bro? They shot a guy with no shot. Apparently, I
don't know what the [__] is going on. Why they shot
driver. Sorry. I thought that was going to be something else.
But if they're looking if the cops were looking at that, they
might also not know either. So,
huh. Well, people are arguing. Icy shot the employee because
of the color of the paintballs. Okay. I mean, we we could look
more into that, but I would need more clips of to see like who
shot who or like how do you how do you see what color the paintballs
are for either of them? Like, are one of them like a wall somewhere
that you could see the difference? reasonable reasonable doubt
then if that's true maybe. H
All right, let me pull this back a little bit. Shuy gets a call
from Zena. Hold on, let me make sure I'm not going to miss anything
here. One of my time stamps was called Shuy throws Zena under
the bus.
Might have to check this out really
Dude, I have no idea what's going on here because the sound is
so bad.
>> How is this exposing?
>> Look at her old mug shot.
for me. >> Okay. Is this a never before seen
>> Dude, I saw Dude, there's um
Did you see the progression of all the Yeah, you saw it yesterday.
The progression of all the Zena mug shots.
>> Yeah. Over time.
Like I don't know this guy, whatever the [__] but
she needs to stay away from
show people.
>> Apparently, these are people with past experiences with
Zena who are warning Shuy to stay away from her. Wow. I don't
know. Shuy Shivy seems to be the guy who can't take any of this
seriously, to be honest with you. >> I mean, >> okay,
hold on. Okay. >> Like I mean this is a lot of not very
serious people. So I don't really blame >> This tab just
crashed. H I kick is so annoying sometimes. I get like tabs that
crash and then they'll play them this song or they'll play the
audio from the clip but the tabs crash so I can't pause it. Sorry.
Go ahead. Saying he's
>> Yeah. You were saying that he's immature.
Think he's immature. I think there's lag or something in this.
But no, what I'm saying is it's I don't blame him for not really
taking any of this seriously because I don't feel like any people
in this whole situation really take themselves seriously. Like
that was kind of an issue I ran into where I I kind of took nothing
going on seriously because I don't feel like any of them
themselves seriously.
So like I I feel that a little bit with like okay you're expecting
me to feel bad for you but you won't do anything to like help
yourself here like a lot of the times when it's honestly dealing
with Darius a lot of the times. Okay. It's just like yeah you're
going to keep having problems cuz you don't take it seriously
don't care. Why should I care if you don't care? That doesn't
make any sense. Okay. Okay. We're good here. We're going to go
over to Was it this stuff? I think I'm just going to go watch
through the calls between Zena and Shuy here. We're going to
finish watching these calls.
cuz I think they called again last night. Maybe this may be the
only calls here. We're just going to keep watching. >> You
have to do a what to the what? >> I can't say.
>> So yeah, Zena is saying get off stream. Get off or mute.
Mute mute.
>> Why didn't everybody tell me? >> Sorry. What did
they say to you?
>> Oh no, I didn't get arrested. I got
>> And then with nobody picking up, I decided to do >> Yeah.
Well, I thought I was going to get arrested, but I didn't. >> Sean,
can you please mute for one minute? Just one minute. >> For
what?
>> All right. I'm lagging pretty heavy. I think I'm going
to bail. Good luck. Much >> All right. We'll talk to you
later. See
>> Can you He lagging. He lagging. I think it's more like
the audio is horrible and I don't even know what we're listening
to right now. >> You just tell me for what?
>> No, I can't.
You're on stream. I really can't. Icy said the phone is not letting
her answer. >> Bro, I need to get a hold of her. Can you
supply I need it on you? >> She said every time that you
call you're she's trying to accept and it's not letting her accept
and it hangs up on her. She's not trying to ignore you. She's
on her stream trying to answer
>> Tell her Tell her to tell Myra to handle it. Like if
she can handle it right now like tell her to go get >> I
know we're talking right here. You just on the phone. >> I'm
pretty sure she can hear you but yeah. Okay. So, she said uh
to tell Myron to handle it. I see. Whatever the that means. >> Yo,
I'm about to merge the call. >> Bro, is that like Myron
Gains? Is Myron going to What is My What is Myron doing? >> What
is Myron doing here? >> I don't know. Cuz that's the reason
why I got banned. I think the jail you can't do three ways. >> So,
should I not add you? >> Yeah, don't add me. I'll just
say just relay the message because of the simple fact that I
tried doing that earlier and I think the jail rejected me for
that cuz every time I'm trying to pick up her call, it keeps
rejecting it. Like it it says this call has not been accepted.
It's not >> bail money. Uh could be could be bail money.
Could be that she's trying to get Myron to pay. >> Like
I'm trying to ignore her. I'm literally on my stream right now
trying to sell Pokemon trying to talk to her. Like trying to
see what's up, but I can't I can't. It's not letting me. >> All right.
So, just tell her anything she needs to tell me. Kimmy's going
to text me. So, she just needs to call Timmy and Timmy will relay
the message.
>> Okay. All right. Sounds good. I'll tell her that. >> All right.
Hello. >> Wait, what does this mean? My exposed for having
a girlfriend and he bailing out Zena. Wait, my had a girlfriend?
Are you talking about That's the same girlfriend he's had for
like three years now. What are you talking about? You asked tree
of logic. That's his beard. I >> She's not on the call.
I didn't merge it because she said she thinks that she's banned
from calling because of merging. I didn't merge it cuz I don't
want to get banned. >> Okay. Tell her to tell Kimmy to
turn on my cell phone. >> She told you to tell Kimmy to
talk to
>> To turn on my cell phone because that's the only way
I can reach Kimmy. >> Turn on your cell. >> They
broke up J Talk. A preach did a video on it. Oh, >> what
does that even mean? >> I need to be able to reach someone.
I have to finish my box. >> I see how you're using global
failing. >> Well, uh I don't know what the message was,
but uh all right. Uh >> he wants just have Kimmy turn the
phone >> Well, that's jail calls for you. Yo, what's up?
>> Is there any way you can tell I
>> Is there any way I can get you Kimmy's phone number?
>> Yeah, cuz I didn't write it down. I was able to put
down >> Yeah, I think I can get you her number. Um, yeah.
It's >> Dude, I I swear to Dude, Shuy's audio is like causing
me psychic damage right now. I'm taking actual psychic damage
from Shuy's audio. Okay.
>> Okay. Sure. Yeah. You You called and I'm answering,
but I'm just saying, what are you telling me this for?
>> You're quiet.
>> It's literally off all the way, bro. You have one minute
remaining. >> Did she give you a number? >> No, not
yet. >> I feel like there's And I understand why you could
like train yourself not to care, but I feel like there's actually
something like psychopathic. There's like actually something
psychopathic with Shuy where like she's like
you could you could say um you say Zena is like playing this
up or acting or something, but when somebody's like crying and
upset, there should be something natural in you that's like I
want to help this person. I don't think I don't think Shuy feels
that at all. I don't think he's got going on in terms of like,
oh, she's upset, so I'm gonna make her feel better.
>> I don't know. >> All right. I mean, there's nothing
you can do. You're locked up. >> It's not muted. I mean,
it's muted, >> Oh, yeah. Allegedly. Yeah. What? What's
>> What do you mean alleged? >> Alle
allegedly?
Yeah. [__] Do you mean allegedly?
The [__] >> You have one minute left.
If you get me [__] over because you didn't mute it.
>> Dude, what do you have to say? You're wasting your seconds.
>> I love you. That's it. That's all I was going to say.
>> Oh, all right. >> Sit down because >> Huh?
You're
>> What? Now he mutes. Now he mutes. Now he mutes it. Are
you serious?
Are you >> Yo, Chad. I don't know what just happened. My
thing just like lagged. But anyways,
let me go see what's up with everyone. Hello. >> Yeah,
she did.
>> You want it?
>> Did Did she give you the number? Yeah. Did you want
it? Oh, I I Oh, you wanted the number? Oh,
holy. >> All right. One second. It's uh Are you ready?
Hey, can I can you release your keys to me?
>> My brother,
>> I don't know what's happening.
Yeah. Yeah. Can I get your house keys? Kimmy has your keys.
>> Okay. Is Kimmy even in Austin?
>> I'll take care of the keys. >> Do you even know
what happened? >> She came and picked up my stuff.
>> Okay. Well, is she still in Austin? Okay. So, can I
live in your house? >> Yes. Yes. >> Oh, okay. Cool.
Also, I wasn't muted when you said that you couldn't sit down.
I'm also unmuted right now, but I wasn't muted when you said
that you could no longer sit down, but I just said like they
didn't understand. They thought it was something weird, but I
didn't explain or I was trying to explain to them that you just
Oh, what the do I need to Hold on. I might have to go find the
actual call.
I Bro, I Hold on. I I I've got the call here somewhere. Just
give me a second. I love clips on Claus, but the mute is too
much. Okay. Mute is way too much. 4 hours 39. >> Yeah.
Yeah. >> That's where we are. 4 hours 39 here. >> Oh,
I was going to say, >> oh, all right.
>> Get my [__] out. I can barely sit down because
of you. >> Huh? You're at this what? >> He insta
mutes this goofy dude.
Instam mutes. Connection lost. Ends the stream. He get his like
spooked face in the pirate. Dude, what?
What? What a what a guy. Hold on. I'm looking for the other phone
call. Okay, it's on the previous stream. Hold on. It's like somewhere
right here, right? It's him on his phone. Calls back somewhere
around here, right? It looked like it was around here.
Rig got this phone call. Yeah, here we go. Austin, house keys.
>> I could go. This is
>> Kimmy has your keys.
>> Oh, okay. Cool. She's acting.
>> So, I guess I'll just ask her for your keys then whenever
I get a chance.
>> Uh, anything else? Also, I wasn't muted when you said
that you couldn't sit down. I'm also unmuted right now, but I
wasn't muted when you said that you could no longer sit down,
but I just said like they didn't understand. And they thought
it was something weird, but I didn't explain or I was trying
to explain to them that you just accidentally What? No.
>> They thought it was something weird like a thing. Yes.
Tell them it's because you put your dick in my ass apparently.
>> What? I >> What? Why would I lie? I'm saying the
truth. There was glass shards in your that you sat on on accident.
Huh?
>> What? This is I dude everybody who watches this guy
and gives him like any any money, any views until he fixes his
audio situation. You all
boycott this stream until he fixes this audio garbage. Okay.
Holy.
Get a directional mic of some kind. It's going to cut out the
cra the car noise in the background, bro. Good lord. I'mma lose
it, dude. >> All right. Goodbye. >> Now he actually
mutes.
Okay. Thousand% boy only likes after play. Oh boy.
>> Okay. All right. You can keep saying this about Really.
It's not. Okay. It's
>> All right. Goodbye.
>> Maybe not here. Why is everybody coming >> There's
like no parks. >> Everybody's pulling up. >> Everybody's
pulling up because they're talking me >> cuz the map's
>> okay. Oh, [__] All right. Um H I think that's
the end of it. I think there there might also be a call with
Icy somewhere.
Let me see if I got a call with Icy somewhere. Maybe we skip
back to this guy. See if there's more here. Calls back at the
end.
>> Mig
why why I'm speak English? Why you speak Korean? >> It's
a way different thing from a couple. Tamman meets MC for the
first time. Okay. I probably am going to watch this. I don't
even know what this is. >> who is that? >> Oh, the
Korean. Oh, I'm I'm serious. Surprise. Where is RFID?
>> You going
>> Why you sit down here? >> No reason. >> No
reason. >> So many insect and humid. Why you >> It's
okay. It's okay.
>> Wait. Oh,
>> wait. Can she speak Korean? What the [__]
What the Wait, she started speaking English with like a Korean
accent. And I was like, "What the why are you why are you like
uh I was like, "Why are you why are you talking like you have
a Korean accent?" And then she started just actually speaking
like really good Korean, I >> No reason. >> So many.
>> No,
no,
it's okay. It's okay. >> No, it's okay. It's okay.
>> She's like warming up to speaking Korean, so she's speaking
English with a Korean accent.
>> Don't you Don't you know Don't you know who am I?
Where are you from?
>> But why? Why? I speak English. Why you speak Korean?
>> dude. She actually speaks flawless [__]
Korean. What the [__] Is she just saying lines she
knows from like movies or pop culture or something? That's like
That sounds so such perfect Korean. This is the last thing I
expected to have happen today. Out of nowhere, Burka is just
speaking flawless Korean to this guy. He's like, "No, she speaks
Korean. What the fuck?" >> But why? Why I'm speak English?
Why you speak Korean?
>> No. No. Why? I You're You are American. I'm Korean.
>> What? Why I'm using English? Why you using Korean? >> I
don't know. >> Just using English. >> Okay. Sorry.
>> How old are you? >> Uh
uh 27. >> 27. What's your name?
>> Why? Why is Murk have it out for Zena? What the [__]
are we doing? >> Why no S?
He knows. He knows. He knows Zena by
No way. That's crazy, dude. What? Well, how did she respond?
Oh, she cursed him. I see. >> She She said to me, she talked
to me. Shut up. Why is she using Korean? I'm using English.
Hey viewers, it was not my fault. She said I'm Gina, right? If
JT said
I am Captain America, then I will say
>> why no shield. >> Where is your shield? Right.
Same. She said I'm Gina. So I said where is your
This program was made possible.
I was like, dude, random clip thrown in at the end. Why not?
I learned so many things from that clip. What the Can we watch
Koreans beating Lety at Hunger Games? Yes, we can. We can watch
the Koreans. We can watch Tam must have been on that team, right?
I feel like that exact voice is was saying, "I am very sorry.
I am very sorry. >> I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I don't want
to kill you." >> That's That's who it is, right? I am very
sorry. I don't want That's the taming guy, right? >> I'm
sorry,
but you're
Why you there?
>> Uh,
this is the best clip from Hunger
>> Yes. Minus one life. Minus one life. >> I'm sorry.
Okay. Just the content just to survivor. You are not. I'm sorry.
>> I'm sorry. I I want you turn back. Very very sad.
Please turn back. I'm sorry. You Why? Why come to weapon? Because
don't go here. Huh? Get up and put your hands up.
You have about 10 life. 10 life. >> I don't know how many
lives I have. Are you going to kill me? My hands are up. >> More.
More. Look at the tree. Look at the tree. Bang. >> No.
I don't want to turn my back. I
>> Don't shoot. Please don't shoot me. Please don't shoot
me. Okay. Oh, nothing. Nothing.
Please don't
shoot.
Don't please don't move.
>> Please. I have Wait, wait, wait. I have block if you
if you I shut your house.
>> Now your life 10. I just I just discount your life just
one. >> Wait. I I can give you
>> Oh, shut up, please. We are not right up. Shut up. We
I want to >> my legs. >> I want to just test. >> Shut
up. >> Please don't shut up. >> I can give you No.
Shut up. Shut up. We are not team. >> Please don't kill
me. >> I want Okay. Back. Back. Back. Back. >> No.
I don't I don't want you to kill. Are you going to kill me? It's
>> Shut up. I will kill you. I will kill your eyes.
>> Jesus Christ. >> I have I have floppy. >> I
don't I don't want kill you. Turn. Let's turn. Three, two, one.
>> Don't. I want to this. >> Okay, stop.
>> Okay, can I go? Can I please go? >> 1 3 2 1 >> Don't
shoot me. >> Hey, don't move. We are not team. >> Then
can I go? >> Can I go? Can I please shut up? Shut up. >> I
just go? >> Put your hands up. Like this. Like this. >> Can
I go? >> No, you can. You cannot go. Put your hands up.
Put your hands up. We want to just test. Put your hands up. >> You're
going to kill me. You're going to kill me.
>> I'm not joking.
I still have a hunch
and I don't know if this is true. Okay, I know that Murk says
this is not true. I still have a hunch that she's got rich parents.
I'm not joking. I think she came from like a wealthy family.
That's like an intuition on my part. Okay. And I know that like
a lot of things around it don't make sense cuz she like I don't
know is like pretty desperate to make streaming work. I think
she came from a rich family. Two things make me think this. Three
things make me think this. She was originally going to be a vet.
Okay. She's originally going to be a vet. She
Oh, four things. She knew a lot about horses. She's been around
horses a lot. Her teeth are almost perfect. She had really good
dentistry when she was a kid. Okay. She probably got braces early.
Her teeth are like almost perfect. They're white. And there's
four. What is four? Another Korean thing. Speaking Korean. No,
I thought Merc was rich from the first second I ever saw her
on a stream. That she came from like a rich family. MC. I'm talking
about Merc. Maybe. Maybe. Evil Johnny Bravo.
Maybe. >> I want just test. Put your hands up. >> You're
going to kill me.
>> Hey, please shut up.
Put your hands up. I want to just test like this. Okay. >> Is
that the last one? Can that be the last one? Can it be the last
one? >> Shut up. I want I want >> What happened?
Uh after this I think I'm going to move and watch the uh the
Ice Beside Darius Christmas Thanksgiving. I think I'm finally
going to watch that. Okay, we're going to watch this after the
Koreans. Okay, cuz I after this it's like we'll move on from
kick drama. We'll probably go back to doing some more like debate
stuff, some some like interesting political stuff again. Okay,
we've we've had our slop arc. We'll finish Hunger Games. We'll
see if there's anything left over there and then we'll be back
to our regularly scheduled programming a little bit. Okay. >> Can
you let me go?
>> Can you please let me go? >> I want to just test.
>> How many times? >> How many times are you going
to hit me? >> It's my mind. Shut up. >> How many
times are you going to hit me? >> Shut up. Don't >> uh
tape that. That That clip is gone. What was that? What was that
clip? That clip's gone.
She gone.
Sorry.
>> Nothing, man. I will. She made a break for it. >> Stop.
Wait. Stop hitting me. >> Oh, don't don't move. I I tell
you, don't move. Hey. Hey, don't move. Don't move. It's a survivor.
Okay. What do you want? >> I just want to go.
>> You just want to go dance. >> That's That's up.
That's Oh, making her dance. That's up. >> Not I promise.
This is >> Sorry. They're just running, right?
>> This is her dancing.
>> Back. Back. Come back. Come back. >> Oh, what
do you want? >> To go. >> To go.
>> But I want I want we are make a team. But this is your
survival. I don't trust you survivor. Okay. >> I promise.
>> Your promise. You promised me.
>> Oh, this is real survivor. Price is
I don't I think
>> Okay. I've gotten more than enough out of this. Okay.
>> There's no way. >> Apparently Merkand Darius is
teaming up >> I need to find You said what? Need to go
to the bathroom.
>> Can you ask for what? >> Tamman lost the 100 the
100k gambling within one week by the way from winning Hunger
Games.
That's nuts.
Come on, >> You kind of >> These people are crazy.
>> Suck at that.
>> Wait, isn't that that guy from Ghost
>> I think that's that guy from Ghost
>> All right. Well, they're hanging out again. That's always
obviously going to end well. Clip was broken. Morei.
Oh, we're gonna we're gonna go with this. All right. We'll go
with this. If we keep going after this, I don't know. I don't
know what to do between the next piece of content will probably
be uh what aerodite
the aerodite Tim Pool Alex Stein thing Alex Stein Tim aerodite
and someone else
I noticed that got put up that might be good we'll see if that's
going up she block says Sam Bond by the >> no call Sam
Bond that's the real content
>> I don't know that but >> Sam Bond's saying that
you he blocked you and you're an obsessed weirdo >> I do
like Sam Bond too though. I like Darius. I like you, but I do
like Sam Bond a lot. >> I think Sam Bond's a chill guy.
I think he's kind of like a >> Brook yesterday was going
on a rant about how much of a POS Darius is and how she will
never do content with him again.
Unlucky. Ice is farming relationships here. Yes, Ice. This is
the thing. Ice has the camera and he keeps asking questions and
I believe we cut into this too late actually. I think before
this Ice is pushing them in this direction to start talking about
this as well, but you actually miss it. >> Crybaby. Damn,
that's crazy. >> I think he's like a chill dude, >> bro.
He a shorty though. He young, bro. That was >> Yeah, he's
young. That's what I'm >> Young, bro. He good people. He
grew up on me a lot. >> Sam, so wait. Okay, Zena, you just
didn't want to date Sam, right? >> I didn't want to be
sexual with him.
>> Wait, so can I ask you? >> Were you sexual?
>> I was going to ask somebody. >> Were you where
you at?
>> What is What is he saying? Hey, could you not do like
content on this? Hold >> Right. I was going to ask >> hurt
somebody. >> Where? I don't want to say the wrong thing
to hurt somebody. Oh, Ice knows that now that there's a wrong
thing that hurts somebody. Oh, well, let's keep >> Where
you at?
Let me just say right now. >> He didn't know how to >> doggy
on you right now. You have to go harder. Remember, >> who's
doggy on me? >> He's saying, "Bro, this is bad, bro. I
blocked her before she blocked mine." >> You're saying
he didn't know how. >> Okay. Did he? Did he? >> I
saw you guys.
Let's be honest. >> You don't know. You do know.
>> You just told me that. I'm sorry. Real quick. You just
gave me a whole story. >> I talked about Instagram and
Discord. That's not the same. And then I said he hit me up through
a Twitter. >> I saw Sam.
>> So you block him. >> What? How? >> I'm pretty
sure I'm pretty sure Kimmyy's sitting here. And from what I remember,
Kimmy just wanted a nice Thanksgiving with friends.
Chill Thanksgiving. We all sit down. We all have a nice time.
And what she got instead,
how do we go back to this fight? Uh, Ice is now moralizing about
how it's so wrong that people humiliated him like this. And I'm
like, I don't think it's that wrong. I think you kind of do the
same thing all the time. Like all the time, actually.
I'm looking at Nick. Dary
wants me. I told him I don't >> on my number. Who knows?
I don't. >> So he's valid.
>> Why does that matter? because he's telling you right
now what he's doing. What he's doing is he's trying to say that
he blocked you and you kept trying to message me. So you need
to like >> Yeah, you guys are saying vice versa. >> I
don't think he's being [__] in saying that because
you >> No, he is dog. >> What he said was I said
call him to get this out of the way. He's literally clowning
on say I'm not [__]
>> He is he is saying it in the chat. I'm not I'm not trying
to say I'm just saying that I blocked her number. Okay, that
doesn't keep saying asked me why I blocked her. Wait,
I'm sorry. >> This is actually true that this gets a little
more [__] up when you realize that a that Nick White
did Jamie Action Man's girlfriend who's sitting at the table
between Action Man and
Sam Bond >> pretended to me for like 5 minutes and I talked
to >> then stop talking over me. I don't know. I don't
even know if you cut off people you were supposed to cut off.
All I know
>> Imagine if >> Well, how's that situation? Imagine
if I >> imagine how's that situation going. >> cuz
this is how mine is. November 16
hit me up and said you blocked me on IG but I thought >> you
blocked me on IG. Of course I blocked you on Instagram.
kind of gay ass. >> This is Kimmy right here. I [__]
blocked him. What? >> So did he block me first? Who? I
don't give a saying. >> Talking loud isn't taking something.
>> Sam, call Nick White. Yeah, Nick, you're lowkey the
somehow the center point of >> Dude, this Nick White guy
has fried every dopamine receptor in his entire skull, right?
There literally is not a dopamine receptor left in this dude's
skull at all. Whenever I see this guy, he seems I think he's
on drugs and super depressed at the same time. That's [__]
up. Okay, he's just never
I've never seen him engaged with anything. Maybe maybe he does
his own stream. I wonder if I could find like highlights of this
guy cuz I know this guy used to be like uh Nick White coding
YouTube.
This is all I know about this guy is he had a 400,000 sub channel
where he did like coding streams
and like I think it was like a good stream or something. A good
a good channel. Apologizing to tech lead. Oh, that's not a good
every coding interview ever. I don't something else secret way
to land. He used to code for he used to be at Google, right?
He's a programmer at Google. Doesn't even look like the same
guy to be honest. >> The name's Nick. Nick White.
>> There's like something I can tell it's the same guy.
Sorry. But it's like uh if you guys haven't heard of this, there's
this very top secret way of uh getting an interview at Google.
It's called Google Fooar. I first heard about this in 2017. Some
of my friends were doing this challenge, passing it around college.
And when you beat the challenge, you can send it to someone else's
email for them to complete the challenge. One of my friends was
just doing a Google search with a bunch of developer type keywords
in it. Not for any reason, but he was just looking up maybe something
in Java and he got the invitation. So, Google is always looking
for some of the best developers and while you can just apply
through their job sites to like software engine set up with Google.
It looks like I completed the first level maybe. I think that's
what's going on here. Yeah. So, I don't know if this is when
I did it last time, but I think there's specific keywords that
you can type into Google and get this challenge. What will happen
after you complete all five levels? After you complete five levels,
you'll get some fields to fill in your details, contact details,
blah blah blah. You'll get call or mail from Google after one
or This is old. He honestly seems kind of chill chilled out here,
too. So, maybe not that much has changed to be honest with you.
Hold on one second. Quick clip. Quick clip. Quick clip.
Man, I uh I really really did not want to go live. I really don't
>> want to be here. I'm not going to lie.
>> But I have an obligation to all the contestants competing
in the scavenger hunt to give them, you know, the uh event and
try to try to, you know, keep the event going, try to finish
up the event uh at a normal pace that it was originally supposed
to be. But I am very angry, very upset. I am mentally, emotionally,
completely scattered, completely
uh you know, I've been I've been made to be I've been made out
to uh as a fool. >> I'm completely embarrassed. I look
like I just look like a fool to say. I am about her. I I just
I have nothing to say. It's >> Wait, what?
>> No, no, no, no. Eat, eat, eat. Are not >> Hold
on. Are we sure? Okay, Blackout. She gave me this time stamp.
I think this time stamp's totally wrong, right? It must be before
this or something. The time stamp seems to like not be. Am I
crazy? Fast forward.
world.
It's just these people are just I [__] on Goon. I
could [__] on Lav, but that's just a I mean, what
what am I supposed to do? I mean, it's just not worth my energy.
It's not worth it. It's just these people are just bad people.
>> We saw that, right? We saw how this like kind of gets
nudged. Do we all see that right now? has got nudged open >> and
this is what they want. There's just >> like a prison break
stream that without I mean I would just it would just be souping
to their level. I mean it's and it's just what they want. It's
it's
>> It's real tough. You know, the thing that really bothers
me though is that, you know, >> Goon,
this guy I have given so much opportunity to, so much money.
You know, I helped him try to get his KCIP fixed when it was
a dollar an hour. I brought him to the Hunger Games, all these
things. Gave him stake streams, you know, because he has zero
dollars in his bank account. He told me he's poor, has zero dollars
in his bank account. I gave him a stake stream. Now, if we recall,
okay, Nick was just cooking on these burners right here. Okay,
>> give him a chance to make money. I just, you know, I
did so much to help that dude. And all I got in return
was him holding something over my head that I had no idea about
for the past year until he saw
an opportunity where he felt like he didn't need me anymore.
So then he could try to use this against me to try to gain viewers
from it. Okay. He married this girl Lav. He makes money >> I'll
just point out that all of his food I think was sitting right
here. So the bird did just I think walk across all of his food
as well >> of his wife's only fans now. So he's like well
I can live off my wife's only fans even though they're all leaked
online. You can watch it completely for free and you don't need
to buy her Only Fans. And she sucks dog as shown on the internet.
If you search her name you'll see a video of her sucking a >> Was
he cookie on this one or is he cooking on this one >> on
video? Okay
now. So he didn't he felt like he didn't need me anymore. So
he completely he held withheld information to throw me under
the bus at a certain >> which is completely disgusting
after everything that I've done to help that >> Wait, he
was cooking on the flat. >> If you were a real man, you
would have came to me manto man a year ago and you would have
told me what? Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Hold on, little birdie.
We got to wait. We got to go back and see what he was cooking
on. Hold on. Hold on. Are you serious? You're going to you're
going to break on me again.
Really? Right now, kick. Holy
moly. >> You told me >> I got to go. >> You
know, hey, I just want to let you know this is the situation.
Instead,
>> you know, hey, I just want to let you know this is the
situation.
>> Instead, he held the information until he saw an opportunity
to try to get one over me, which is [__] disgusting.
I've been [__] over by so many people in my life,
but I will I mean I I will say this is probably the >> And
now it's crying. No, it was crying the whole time. >> Worst
[__] >> I don't know. It's possible that it
wasn't quite so bad. Like it's >> anybody's ever done to
me to me over.
>> I just cannot
people in this world,
>> man. I healing on this middle part. Yeah. Yeah. did
not want to go live.
But that's just a I mean what small I go out of online you can
watch
and [__] the situation a real man you would have
came to me manto man >> on this flat top part >> a
year ago and you would have told >> he's fine he's fine
he's fine he's fine >> you know hey this is the situation
>> instead he held the information until he saw an opportunity
to try to get one over me which is disgusting I've been over
by so many people >> holy [__] and a new case
guy.
>> Hey, what's up? Yeah. Yeah, I think so. I appreciate
you letting me know. Yeah, I don't know how you I don't >> I'll
be real. I don't know how much that's on Nick. Okay. I don't
think this makes Nick like a total [__] He seems
to care about his birds and he thought he had the cage closed.
I feel like that's a mistake that could happen to a lot of people.
I don't feel like I totally blame Nick for that. >> How
you got across? >> Sorry, just in case anyone was like
Nick's like a total piece of [__] for this or something.
I appreciate that. Thank you.
>> That might be true. If Emran did that to his bird. Holy.
>> That'd be like four more dogs that would go missing.
>> Yeah. I may, you know, have banter. I I make fun of
people and you know, whatever. It's all just content banter.
>> But there's a line eventually.
>> Pretty hot though. How do I guess I can watch my own
stream
ever again. That's pretty rough anymore. I don't >> Okay,
you shouldn't be anywhere near the stove. Probably not. How annoying
would it be to live with a bird squawking all day? Pretty annoying.
Yes. Their house looks so trashy. I don't know why they don't
clean. They like they actually are like hoarders.
It's very weird to be like that rich and just hoarders. Like
totally, you know? Some odd. Okay, hold on. Let's uh let's hop
over to this. Apparently, there's a little bit more going on
here. All over the place. We got Shuy and Squeeze apparently
went and picked up a random homeless guy. >> It's his that's
his that's his that's his property. That's his It can be It can
be a a business.
>> I don't know what's going on, >> bro. When you
smoke, bro. >> Bro, look. >> I don't know, bro. This
is too much, >> Smoke, bro. When it comes to >> Dude,
this is a law, bro. Here, take this bleach, my boy. >> Bro,
I've drunk bleach.
>> I've drunk bleach. >> Right now,
No, no, no, no.
>> Why you drink that, bro? >> You're dying. >> What
in the [__] is happening? >> It taste good.
>> Are you [__] serious? >> It tastes
good. Clean your system. What's wrong with you? You ain't know
>> My point Those are chemicals, my boy. >> What
that mean?
>> Got chemicals in it. >> What that mean? >> No.
has >> everything got chemicals, boy. >> That has
chemicals, too. You ready? >> Wake up. >> I'm up.
>> Wake up and smell the coffee.
>> wake up. I I have to wash, but wake up. >> How
does that [__] taste? >> Wake up and smell
the coffee. It's It was actually pretty good. >> Tastes
like It smells >> Feel like having a tiny capful, you probably
don't hurt yourself too bad, right? Right. Like it's it's bad,
but I feel like you'd have to drink a little more than that to
cause like major major
Try it. No, I'm good. >> All over a man's car. Bro, you
got to go, bro. >> Look, my >> He basically like
poured it onto the cap and then flicked the cap at his face,
right? He spit it out. I think you can see him edge outside the
car.
>> that was crazy. >> When it came to my pup
and get out, dog, >> you spilled bleach all over homie's
car. >> It was a mess. So good. >> I think you'd
be scared of getting like ulcers or something, right?
>> Neutralize it with the soda. I mean, you neutralize
it a little bit maybe, but you don't neutralize it that much.
The soda is what?
>> Soda pH would be like five, four legend. Oh, pH. No,
no, no. Common items or something. This is what I was looking
for. Can I Can I get a picture? Hello. Oh, you don't even get
soda in here. You'd think soda would be somewhere around vinegar
and wine, right? Soda pH. But bleach is up here at 13. Can I
Hold on. What? PH of most sodas falls between 2.5 and 3.5. Okay.
Yeah. Okay. Between vinegar and wine. Lemon. Lemon and wine rather.
I mean, you neutralize it a decent amount. I think is this like
a linear scale in terms of costicness though? I don't think it's
like a linear scale, right? This has to be like a I don't know
if parabolic would be the right word, but it's not a linear scale.
It's exponential. Yes. Okay. So, parabolic would have been correct.
Yeah, it's got to be exponential cuz you think like soap is fine
and then bleach and drain cleaner like you're like insanely costic,
right? And then like lemon's fine, stomach acid, then hydrochloric
acid. Logarithmic. Would it be logarithm? I I'm I'm saying in
terms of costic
costicness you'd go up, right? based on logs. Well, hold on.
Am I insane or are logs not just Okay. Logs by the power of 10.
Okay. Okay. All right. Look at the bottom minus log of the hydrogen
the positively charged hydrogen atoms. Okay. Oh my god. I don't
I don't remember basic chemistry. I'm I'm going to look if I
talk about any of this. All good. Okay. Are we finishing? What
are we finishing? Thanksgiving. I just closed the clip. My god.
Willis
>> with you under kind of gay assess. >> Finishing
up Thanksgiving. Okay, we're finishing it up. >> I don't
give a >> talking loud isn't taking away
>> Sam, call Nick White. >> Yeah, Nick, you're lowkey
the somehow on >> Oh, we went off. We went off on a Nick
White tangent. >> I thought she was messaging me. >> Dude,
I thought we were just
I thought we were doing this >> weird whatever and I said
cool and I left it alone. Then he's like hitting me up asking
how I'm doing. Man, your fans are poor actually, man. You got
$10 ETSs. Not a single one. >> Every person that's gifted
a sub last five people are from me. >> Dude, you are being
dog. You going like this is not
you going like do you want to read them >> Dude, I really
don't give a really right now. Right now it's like
me entertaining like >> All right. Say what you got. >> Guys,
we got 10 minutes left in the stream if you wanted another hour.
Okay, which would include this and I don't know. We'll see what
go ahead and donate. If not, we got 10 minutes left. I think
we'll mostly finish this. Okay, we'll get through it. >> What
do you mean, bro? I just don't like getting lied about, bro.
I block No, you blocked me on Instagram because you messaged
me.
>> Why I blocked you on everything? >> And then we
were in mid conversation.
>> Dude, you're not getting gas.
>> No way. A lot of people die every year from overdoses
because they vomit into their mouths and then inhale it. They
wake up and seem fine for hours, but their lungs are getting
raed by the acid and they die of infection. That's wild. What's
the What's the cure for that? What What do you like flush into
your lungs that you would fix that? >> Like you're gaslighting
the dude to your left, bro. Okay, >> you came on my stream
and you gifted
subs that same day.
>> Yeah, I gift a lot of people subs. What the [__]
>> Yeah, but wait, pause. Why are you blocked? But you're
gifted and then I blocked you and you got mad that I blocked
you, bro. >> No, I didn't. No, I didn't. You got mad. You
got mad. You got mad that I blocked you. Okay, we're having a
mid conversation on Instagram.
>> This is Nick White calling Sam Bond to get Sam Bond
to do this conversation. >> Twitter burner, but that's
what you're >> I don't know. He's claiming to block me.
I'm the one that blocked the DMs. I have the [__]
What the [__] >> So do I, Sam. At the end of
the day, here
listen. Hey, Dar. Hey, you >> No. No. How about this, Sam?
Sam, what happened with all of that? Did I or did I not say I
didn't want romantic things from you? Right. >> My best
friend. >> Okay. Yeah. Like, bro, we stop talking. >> I
cut you off and said I don't want to be romantic or sex with
any of y'all >> talking like that anyways >> because
I was being distant. Yeah. And guess who I Yeah, exactly. And
you had a problem with that. And I still have those messages
too. Admit that.
>> Thank you for admitting that. >> Okay. If you
blocked my number, Sam, I
>> because what you came in the chat was trying to make
it like I was hitting you up to try to be with you. Nobody hit
you up to try to be with you. >> Poor guy. Oh, I feel bad.
>> It's that simple. I feel bad for you because you were
crying that I didn't let him talk. Let him talk >> and
I told you you don't know how to >> That is exactly why
I didn't want to be with you and I told Jamie that and I have
the messages with Jamie where I told her that you don't
know how to you suck, bro. You suck. Your dick is weak. I'm sorry,
bro. Weak
and that's what happened. So, who do you feel bad? >> Someone
do. I'm thankful for >> Wait, I'm >> Wait, did he
did he does he eat your
>> Jamie? Come on, >> Jamie. Don't blow this Twitter.
>> I told Nick White the same thing.
>> He's just like He doesn't care. He's like, "Guys,
just give me a turkey leg. What are you What are you doing?"
>> I didn't have to enjoy that. I had
>> What was wrong with his but No, no, no. Here's the thing.
Paul, Paul, Paul. She booked my flight to Miami to come though.
So that's like really interesting. Like if I'm not doing it right,
then why would you book my flight to Miami? Because because you
wanted to >> size that matters. It's I told him and I told
Sam, too. It's not that he's bad. It's just he doesn't like it's
>> Does he Does he eat your good >> anonymous $66?
>> Yes. Wait. He just realized they had
>> Wait, this is the craziest. >> Oh, wait. Did you
Wait, you didn't know >> As a person. >> Oh, he just
realized that that uh Well, what I think Darius actually realizes
here is that Zena said, "Well, we didn't have unprotected."
I think that's what they realize in this. But it's like Darius
is on stream, right? Darius is on stream being humiliated by
Ice Poseidon directly, right? Directly. He's farming this. He's
farming it hard. doesn't give a about Darius farming his relationship
drama farming he didn't know about his girlfriend right
how in the does he get off on like trying to say Gunnar's a total
piece of [__] >> because he's a nice guy and
he's really sweet and he's >> wait Zena wait a second you
didn't tell Darius Wait Sam you didn't tell Darius that you had
Sam
>> Was it with or without I'm having too much fun right
now >> I don't know that >> was it with >> so
I Oh we're totally farming this Oh this is a right time. Why
don't we just farm this guys? Isn't this totally cool to farm?
Isn't this like isn't this totally no problem? Wouldn't this
be really cool?
And then Gunnar does this exactly to him or sorry, Gunnar and
Lab do this exactly to him and suddenly everybody loses their
minds
without a condom.
>> Wait, look how much weight. And guess what? Uh Darius
isn't Darius is actually okay. He does melt down a little bit
later, but Darius is at least holding it together. He's making
jokes. He's not like that didn't happen. That that didn't happen.
>> Did you come inside of her? >> You look really
good, man. God, I feel like a fat. >> Yes, I this will
happen for sure. >> I remember this happening too. We all
know that. >> We know the answer then. I mean, >> wait,
answer that. Actually, answer that. Wait, I not answer. >> I
mean, that's the answer. You already answered that. >> Same
as your situation. It's exactly the same as your situation. >> No
way. Like >> you actually did lie to me though. >> I
mean that that's kind of crazy that you didn't tell Darius though.
>> He's joking for the stream. He's known since they happened.
>> No. No. Cuz now I'm actually >> So what he does
find out he knew that they [__] Okay. I I don't know
if Ice knew that he knew. Ice was ready to farm that. I think
what Darius actually realizes is that Zena said we had with a
condom, but they actually had unprotected. And that makes a really
big difference to Darius. I guess
>> it's gonna it's gonna
>> Okay. When you >> might want to pour for this
one. I don't >> All right. I'll take some. >> Bro,
if if I beside had to live like a day and a half in Darius's
shoes, he'd kill himself. I'm not joking. Okay.
>> I'll take some more wine with this [__]
>> What is this? What is my situation? >> What do
you mean? >> Not good. >> So, here's what you uh
Good one, Globe Hard. What? Who did I say to call? Who did he
say to get on the phone?
Is it It's almost like he got the guy who Dina on the phone
at Thanksgiving dinner.
>> Message me. Okay. >> I used a condom. I used a
condom. I need to know that you use a condom because I want to
feel comfortable. So cap so glad that you know that.
>> Oh man.
>> No. Cuz I'm glad that you're a liar and >> I literally
told you as Wait, we have messages as >> real. This won't
end.
>> Oh Sam, you just ruined this relationship. Oh, ICE seems
really broken up about that. ICE seems really concerned that
hey, we had no respect for these people's privacy. We had no
respect at all. >> Why are you
got this? >> I'm negative for everything. I got tested
for everything. Negative all over the board everywhere. >> I
don't believe that.
>> Action man definitely got herpes or something. For sure.
For sure. Who would not bet on this? >> You're misunderstood.
>> He did not know that. Darius didn't know. Okay, we literally
see the DMs where Kimmy tells both Goon and Lav that Ice knows
and not to [__] with him so he doesn't leak it. Are
you trying to prove that they're the exact same situation or
you trying to disprove it? Cuz I you're you're definitely proving
it's the exact same situation right now. Thank you. >> Okay,
so you have multiple people >> It's fine. No one here uses
a condom. >> That has no idea
free because he's not a nasty dirty ass person and he got tested.
>> Sam Bond got tested. How do you know? >> Because
he showed me. >> He had a prostitute on stream and you
know what he
showed you? What did he show you?
>> Okay, cool. You have >> show me like
>> Wait, what website? >> I don't place. Where did
he go? >> What? On back page or something?
>> Random papers on his bookstep.
>> Dude, I I'm I'm actually I'm genuinely
>> from a show. >> Dude, Darius is >> They're
caring, guys. >> Did they? You guys said Darius wasn't
making noise. He carried Darius >> Kimmy was so pissed
this whole time. It's so funny >> the stream, guys. It's
not be your eyes beside you. >> You did. Don't talk to
me. >> How did That's not a lie. >> that's literally
not. >> No, they know what you did, bro.
>> It's not about STDs. It's about It's the principle of
the respect.
>> No, I
They already knew it though. She already knew it. They're choosing
to be here together, though. Remember, they both walking together.
>> What happened? They both know what >> Good point,
Jamie. >> They both know.
>> I don't think Ice brought it up to [__]
them over in the same way. But the whole the thing Ice is referring
to is like the the betrayal, the lack of respect. There is no
respect here. He treats people with zero respect, right? He farms
their relationships. He has no respect for their privacy, no
respect for any of that [__] at all. And do you think
if he do you think he wouldn't have farmed this? Like it's just
who he is. And that's fine if that's what if that's the content,
if that's how you make a living, whatever. Okay. Just don't get
when people do it back to you. That's all. >> But they
love each other though. They're so in love with each other, bro.
>> They're so in love, dude. So in love. >> I mean,
I would be very if I was in his shoes. Another man came beside
you. >> You know what I'm saying? >> They were on
a break, bro. They were on a break. Heyo.
>> Uh, I was I was totally ready to be I was about to I
was out of here. Sha Maloney. I was out of here. Hey, you just
come in and drop 25 gifties. Okay, massive 25 gifty. All right,
thanks. 25 gifted. Oh my god. Uh, that's probably like
that's probably two more hours on the stream. Damn.
Damn. God damn.
Okay. All right. >> I would be very if I was in his shoes.
>> Yes. That's all it is. Stoked. It's just his ego. It's
just his ego. Sean Maloney, thank you very much for the 25 gifties.
Okay. We're going to keep going. Two more hours. >> Another
man came beside you. >> No. You know what I'm saying? >> That's
impossible. >> Cool. Because if you love each other, >> because
you're not a total psychopath, you get a reward. What? >> No.
No. I'm not hearing you out for >> No, because you're trying
to
cuz right now what I have to do is I have to put myself in another
reality where I didn't ask these questions and I'm like this
like I don't know. Please come to me. Please come to me. But
that's not me. I know what I did and I know how I interacted
with you to engage where we're at right now. >> Yo, chill.
That's what I'm doing. That's why I'm telling you everything
and I continuously do. >> 2 hours is enough time to watch
Medadia. Uh, that's probably true.
>> Like we're just hope the next right here in my position
does the same exact thing and knows and tells you the same exact
thing so that you will learn a lesson, bro. Because I'm telling
you right now, you are lying. >> I think that Zena loves
Darius. But I but I but I think Zena also a freaky ass
It frustrates me. You want to watch you. >> You know what
I'm saying? If that freak >> is going to off dudes. >> No,
she's not. She's not a freak. >> She would not like that.
>> If the tree was off, I'd still be annoying. You lied
to me. >> She was single. He was sleeping with other girls.
>> No, I know. But I'm saying like I just >> said
that Zena's a freak. >> I said Zena loves Darius, but she
she got that freak in her. >> No. Why? I was with one person.
Dude, do I need Do I need to cancel my ride? >> I just
love I love how much respect Ice Boseidon has for this situ situation
and uh all of this, you know. >> Love it. >> What
is What is Darius upset about? >> He's upset. >> He
thinks that I lied because he's saying I don't think you did.
>> Give me one second. I just need to grab some water.
Use the bathroom. I'll be right back. Okay, here's the thing.
You >> in the beginning. Can I talk to you screaming this
whole time? >> No, cuz you have First off, you've been
talking over me the whole time. But you have to agree. I would
hit him up because before I even was like, >> "Well, just
just answer." Wait a second. Just answer the question. >> I
know he didn't use condoms and I kept trying to find out. >> Why
was he going to use Why is he upset >> The guy at the time
and I was like, "Okay, I want to Why is he upset >> He
cla because in the message where he asked about STD testing,
I flipped it on him to be like, "You're asking me who's been
with one person when you >> Why didn't Why didn't you just
answer the question?" >> He didn't ask me that. >> So,
just he just asked about testing and I answered that. I didn't
broke it after you tested me. >> And then you were like,
"And you're mad." Why? >> I mean, dude, the second I realized
that >> just say why? >> The moment I found out she
was on, I had conversation with her about the situation. And
every time the conversation led to, okay, what happened? It was
a harm
and the conversation was her spinning
or being like, I don't do that. I don't not use cond. So, you're
upset that she's lying about >> I'm upset that she is not
explicitly lying. She is intentionally
spinning the situation on me every time. If I ask you a question
like, "Oh, lying by omission. >> How do you feel about
CS Coin?" You're like, "Didn't you a transvestite last week?"
And I'm like, and I'm like,
>> I'm just telling you guys." All right. I'm just telling
you guys if Lavender actually wanted to come back at this guy,
this would be the stream you refer to, right? where it's like
Ice clearly
doesn't want to stop farming this. He's clearly good to go on
this, right? Doesn't care. He's gonna go. He's having fun and
and like respecting any any like kindness or anything like that.
Yeah. Nothing. Not here at all. >> Wait, what happened
to CS? We're talking about CSC right now. Why am I talking about
Transvestite? That's what's happening every time I'm talking
to her. I'm trying to talk to her about this >> and because
I because I've been getting and because I went this mother pivot
the conversation to something else. Every single time I've been
like, "Okay, so because we're pivoting, we obviously don't care
about this because it's not real." >> Okay, so you you
hear what he's saying. You hear? >> Although, I will say
at the end of Ice's like whole emo rant today, at the very end
of it, he did go, "You know what? Actually,
maybe
I had this coming. Like I maybe this was my karma." And it's
like, "Thank you. Yes, thank you. Thank you." >> You hear
what he's saying? So why are you upset? You hear what he's >> Oh,
I walked away and went to the bathroom. What did he say? I'm
not saying he never has. What a weird straw, man. Or are you
talking to somebody else? Oh, you're talking to somebody else,
right? Hold on. Let me go look at my kick dashboard. You're probably
replying to somebody. >> Yeah, you're
She administrative
at this point. >> Comparison compared to what I've done,
which is
what we which is tell you from
No.
No. Sorry. Real quick. What you've forgiven is fact. I refuse
to talk to you about what's going on. And I told you straight
up, I'm not going to have this conversation with you. What you've
done is tell me I'm not gonna not you're gonna pivot the conversation.
Every time this comes up, you're going to bring up something
else. You're going to make me feel bad instead of you admitting
your wrongs or being like, "Yo, uh, I actually don't want to
talk to you about this." Instead of saying, "Hey, Darius, uh,
I actually I actually don't want to have this conversation."
Instead, what you say is, "Hey, Daryus, aren't you a piece of
>> Samon? Ruin Thanksgiving.
>> You are a gas.
>> He apparently I guess I guess
they're going to skip through all the Kimmy complaints." Kimmy
was about to go off there like, "Hey, what are you doing?" >> I
actually agree with him. I agree with >> No, you're joking
me. >> I No, I agree with him. >> No, he's done.
Look at you guys. You guys are gas too. Look at you. You ain't
bro. You the bro. You mother toxic ass relationships.
be splitting. We're not supposed to be talking. We're not even
doing this.
>> You know I'm doing it. >> So she's looking at
it.
>> I want you I want you to agree. That's my fault. Darius,
>> if if you if you if you know she's gaslighting, why
do you keep arguing? >> All of Darius's content was relationship
drama, whereas Ice has largely not conducted himself the same.
Uh, okay. But Ice has had lots of relationship drama. In fact,
the what was it? The Mango Bay incident is literally relationship
drama. That's like his most famous thing, right? Someone said
that's Peak Ice Poseidon. Literally his relationship. Horseshoe.
Horseshoe Bay. I don't know why I said Mango Bay. Horseshoe Bay.
Jesus Christ. Sorry, I'm not uh I didn't watch streams pre2020,
okay? I just didn't watch streams at all. It's like nothing.
>> You make this [__] >> because because
there's going to be some point where the gas light's going to
just like the gas is going to fade, bro. I'm going to put on
the mask and I'm going to be able to see through the [__]
and I can see
>> what instead of
>> That's not That's not what gaslighting is. There's not
gas. There's not a bunch of gas in the room like that you can't
see through. That's not how it works. We know what gas lighting
is, right? It's like I thought it was like there there's a gas
light on the oven to show the gas is on and somebody like turns
it off and your partner like turns it back on and then tells
you you never turned it off, but they're like intentionally with
you. They're like intentionally lying, right? They're like intentionally
lying to make you seem crazy. No, that's completely wrong. Are
you sure that's not I think I just got it exactly. Mark Carney's
with me. I'm pretty sure
>> no it's like street lights. What? From burning gas.
See gas lighting. See gas light. 1944 film. Hold on. Using lies
to manipulate and isolate his Aerys wife and persuade her she
is mentally ill so that he can steal from her. One of the husband's
tricks is to secretly dim and brighten the indoor gas lighting.
Insisting his wife is imagining it. Oh wow. I didn't know. I
didn't get it right.
Damn. Well, there you go. Boom. Yeah, I was wrong. Many such
cases. Okay. I was pretty sure I had that. I thought I had it
right. I thought that was the whole point.
But this seems to be like way closer to Listen, this might be
uh Oh, what is it? Uh Mandela effect thing for me. Okay. This
might be a Mandela effect thing thing for me. All right. What
if a narcissist doesn't know they are lying because they believe
their own delusions? What's it called? Um it's still gaslighting,
right? Does gaslighting require the intent? You're still like
using a
Maybe. Maybe. Maybe. Still pretty bad.
Let's continue >> because there's a stream on so everything
feels way more pressured than if the stream was off. >> Nobody
has a perfect
>> Wait, did he not literally say the thing about the gaslight
mid movie? I I thought that's what it was. Babka I Yeah, but
maybe not.
>> On my mom's on my >> You guys validating this
is insane. Their relationship is
>> their relationship is so far gone. It's >> It's
not cuz they love You're a great example of that. But >> Oh,
for sure. Paul. Yeah. You're just the most standup guy of all
time. >> Yeah. I mean, >> yeah. You're just there.
Yeah. Paul, you've never done anything shady or wrong or direct.
>> My relationship is one of the best >> right now.
Maybe. What if we were to rewind two or three? >> Aren't
we in love, Kimberly? >> We are very much in love. >> They're
in love right now, but they they're they're working through it
for you to sit here like you Jesus Christ when I know >> I'm
not Jesus Christ. I'm ice besided.
Let's take a shot. >> Dude, this like the only time Action
Man's ever been like tried to be content on a stream from what
I've seen. >> We need to do something else. >> Prior
to this, you didn't. >> No. Yeah, it was supposed to be
>> Kimberly, do you want to make $10,000
just No, no, no, no. It's all right. Just let it happen. >> Well,
that's why you're literally not at the price of my friends. It's
all right. Let it happen. It's all right. Let it happen. Just
let it just let me work. Okay? You want to make money, dude.
It's so clear who this guy is. And it's so clear that it's embarrassing
for him to pretend,
okay, to pretend that he doesn't do this kind of that he respects
people. Like, it's just it's it's just wild. It's wild to be
this fragile after building an empire this way.
No, they're slightly different. Globe hard. They're slightly
different. The emotional turmoil that Ice and Darius are going
through would be roughly equivalent. And Ice doesn't see Darius
as somebody worthy of respect or somebody he should care about
at all. And Ice sees himself as somebody like that. That's what
I'm telling you. But the rest of the internet, the rest of the
normal people all see Ice as the same as Darius. Ice and Darius
are basically the same person to 99.9% of the planet. Do you
understand that?
of the planet, they're the same person. But Darius knows that
he should take that he can take this and move forward.
And I think that the Yeah, they're basically the same. They don't
do the same content. I'm telling you that they do content that
abuses other people that that takes advantage like monetizes
other people's pain, right? And causes it like causes it. No
people see Darius as poor. Okay, fair enough. >> Fair enough.
That's a pretty big >> I'm trying to think about my future.
>> That's pretty massive. Oh, you know what? You're >> That
was the scummiest thing anyone said tonight. She was being noble
and you had to like Bro, you got no chill, bro. >> Who's
being noble? >> No, I'm trying to think about our >> But
I'm saying no. Kimberly was trying to say like she don't want
to get money and like and like >> if Zena was hanging off
a volcano with your child, who do you say that >> your
child or Zena?
>> Your child, right? The money's going to your child.
He's literally he's literally explaining why he doesn't care
about people
>> Subie, go downstairs.
>> But I'm saying but like, dude, the people want to see
this content. Dude, >> the people want to see this content.
No, Darius. Dude, you guys love each other. >> No. No.
Globe hard. Darius didn't get mad at Ice over this because he
can't get mad at Ice because he's financially dependent on the
connection to Ice Poseidon. You understand that, right? That
Darius was probably pissed about this. Daryus is probably [__]
annoyed that this guy was just farming his relationship and trying
to get him and his girlfriend to fight, but he doesn't say anything
because he needs the money. That is you've just hit exactly what
the point is. Ice doesn't give a about these people, but they
have to pretend they care about him. They can't treat him equally
because he's holding the stick with the money on it. Okay. He's
holding the carrot. Darius is on the CX plantation. Exactly.
So maybe Ice doesn't realize this. Maybe Ice got a little reciprocity,
okay, in how he was treating people and he couldn't handle
>> No, he does not care. You're wrong. You're just wrong.
>> Wait, how much ETH do you have? >> How many ETH
do you have? >> I don't keep any or BTZ.
>> Oh, you were in Stillcoin. >> And what? >> Still
coin.
>> I don't >> What is that? >> You mean stable
coin? Oh my goodness. That was 8 months ago. Oh, that's rough.
>> I have a little bit in BTC ETH, but I keep most of it.
I just keep in the I keep a lot of in the wallet. >> What
is Stillcoin? >> Steak. I keep a lot of in the stake wallet.
You keep your [__] in state state cash. >> Not
all of it. >> You know, dude, you know how you >> Many
of it. A large chunk of it. >> You keep a large chunk of
your money in state cash. >> I spend it if I put it in
the bank. >> Oh no. In the bank.
>> what is your dad doing? >> He doesn't know what
I'm doing. >> Oh my god. So, what should I do?
>> I've made over a million dollars in the past week because
of ETH going up. Piece
It was free >> because you said nice. >> What are
you doing? Like I >> Why don't you want to help me [__]
with this argument? >> Ice doesn't even have to apologize.
That's the funny thing, Cherry. Okay. Ice doesn't even have to
apologize.
He can do this. He's built like a whole thing where this is the
this is how it works, right? When there's relationship drama,
they all farm each other. They all like make these jokes. They
all do this content out together, right? They have this whole
dynamic.
I just don't like that he's pretending that somebody gave him
back the same energy, maybe even a little harder, but not that
much harder in the same dynamic. Treated him like he was an equal
and he was just like he just lost his say he made 1 million last
week but tells Kimmy to shut up for 10k. Yes, he's a he's a
He's a grabbler. >> I didn't know you were that um didn't
know I didn't know you were that >> I was making 10k a
month until last year. I was making 20k a month tops until last
year. >> Listen, bro. Don't keep anything state cash cuz
it's not doing anything. It's just sitting there. >> Yeah,
but I I'm I'm seeing the money sit there. Wait, there's drama.
So, I >> don't want that to happen to your girl. But she
didn't lie to you because >> uh she she didn't lie to me.
No, she didn't lie to me. She didn't do anything. She said that's
my problem. She didn't lie to me. She didn't give me security.
And then I I >> She giving you all the security. >> She
gave me false security. She gave me false security. false security
by always being there monetarily supporting you being there your
support like physically as in relationship >> the worst
you ever when I asked her for security with like hey
>> she didn't see >> anonymous tip $6 Darius
always
sends his regards
progressive auto insurance is great >> do I look good or
not like why do we why are you making this on on you >> Darius
you're a handsome guy dude >> that's actually not that
far off Darius looking like goon here wait they do actually Look,
they're just like the white and black version of each other,
okay? They're like yin and yang. He's got like the the kind of
mulletish haircut going the mustache.
That's actually true. What the [__] White and Indian.
True.
>> Shut the up, [__] Well, no. All I'm saying
is like I was I when we're not having the conversation on on
me and I'm trying every time I try to have a conversation on
me or what what's going on here uh it has pivoted into this conversation
on how I am a bad person or into how XYZ has happened. >> I
actually majored in psychology. I know the fix for this. The
fix for this is you guys have to have sex in front of
we do. I have only >> I've literally seen D I've literally
seen you guys have sex
Yeah, but I'm talking about in person. >> I literally zoomed
in on Darius's. I was looking at his I was like, is this that
>> I mean, like >> this is a wild thing to be saying
at Thanksgiving dinner. That's like crazy. I watch like your
zoom in on your your massive, bro. >> What am I the only
guy that watches up the stairs at the guy's? >> If I was
telling you if we had a conversation and I said use a condom,
why would you ask me that? Obviously, I'm thinking you're asking
me that because we did talk about stuff. I And I would always,
"Oh, you [__] bra. You [__] raw." I'm
figuring he knows. No one not once did he say, "Did you use a
condom with this man?" Not once. You can't pull up one message
where you asked me if we used a condom.
>> So, prior to that message, right now, right now, what
you just said was that I know that you use a condom and I asked
you that question. And knowing that I know that you use a condom
and instead of answering my question, what you did was say, "Don't
you not use a condom?" Instead of just saying, "Hey, >> yeah,
because I did use a condom." >> He didn't ask directly
and that's my
>> Okay.
Uh maybe Darius is getting gas lit a little bit now. I can't
remember if I
>> direct prior so prior so I so here's here's a situation.
I can't prove it >> I mean, dude, hold on. This is crazy.
If a guy asks, "Did you get an STD test?" He's clearly you're
assuming like you didn't use a condom. Clearly, are you guys
out of your mind? >> That's obvious.
>> This is funny, Accelerate, cuz that was my point as
well was it really depends on how Paul
asked about it, right? If he said, "Can you tell me everything
so I know?"
and then he didn't get she gave him partial answers then that's
kind of [__] up. Okay.
If he said just tell me like high level I don't really want to
know that much. Then I don't know if she did something wrong.
Okay. >> That's why I don't know. That's what he's upset
about. >> So I'm assuming you didn't use a condom or something
like that. But then you're pivoting onto me and I'm like oh so
you must have used a condom. So why am I so why am I so why so
why am I
>> I mean if I ask somebody a question and they answer
my question with a question. I feel like that means whatever
answer they don't want to tell me, whatever answer would make
me annoyed or upset the most is probably what is the answer.
Right? If I ask you a question, if I say, "Hey, did you get an
STD test?" You say, "Do you ever get an STD test?" I assume that
the answer to my question was whatever would upset me, which
is probably
no or something, right? Like, or the condom thing. If if Darius
was talking about condoms, he's like, "Did you get an STD test?"
I don't know, right? Yeah. If they just if they just turn it
back on you, it's like, okay, I assume whatever your answer was
going to be is going to be the thing that pissed me off. >> So,
what about the multiple part? >> But what about the tank
that you're supposed to trust the guy that >> I had one
partner? >> But what about if you're supposed to trust
the guy that's >> [__] your girl? >> I
don't think. Yeah. Yeah. And I had one partner and I'm like,
>> what's the
>> Do you really want to know the fix? >> The fix
to the fix to this >> couples therapy going? No. No. I'm
going to be honest with you. You guys have a lot of res You have
a lot of resentment towards Zena. Hold on. You have a lot of
resentment towards Zena. Zena is a professional gaslighter. I
think you guys should just split up. >> I think you guys
should split up. >> I disagree with that. >> I think
you guys should split up and never never date again. >> Paul,
you're so
Paul. Paulie, you're a sociopath.
>> I'm just I'm just listening for the >> Right.
And that's why you're Ted Bundy
>> he's really not. He's really not. [__] there's
like some overlap here, right? Where um like narcissists can
basically mimic sociopaths as long as it's not like about themselves,
right? With other people, they could be like sociopathic, but
as soon as it comes down to them, they have like perfectly functioning
emotion about themselves. That's probably more what it is, right?
Like Ice just doesn't see other people very well. And then when
it's him that's getting [__] with, he's like, "Oh,
this is horrible. This is horrible." That's probably what's going
on, right? >> Listen, I'm not a Okay. >> Is that
Is that like Max? Was that Max's article? The Mr. Girl article,
the Mr. Girl report where he talked about that like the thing
Trump is >> just it's it was okay. You're not. It was supposed
to be a joke like you're a scumbag. The point I'm trying to make
is that like dude, they love each other and that I do believe
>> all cuz you love somebody doesn't make it right.
>> By the way, I have no formal education. I'm using words
that I don't really know. So, don't take any of that too >> Love
is not the end all be all. >> Correct. But if it's strong
enough and they care enough about each other, it could be like
treading in water. You can you can love they love a lot of people.
>> They have been through so much together and I know they
care about each other a lot and I know Zena. Wait, no. Zena,
>> Zena the stream.
>> Zena, where are you going? >> No. Come on, dude.
I wasn't supposed to get this far, bro. >> This is stupid.
>> Dude, turn the stream off, bro. >> I mean, that's
Keep it on, then. I don't know. I don't want them to say I I
>> I know. They're all mad. >> I ruined the stream.
I didn't ruin the
>> Happy Thanksgiving, everyone. It's like $10,000.
>> I know, but people are going to end up >> Paul
has millions of dollars. Huge >> You can cry in your Lamborghini
later. >> Oh, you're so weird for that. >> You have
one.
>> You can just see. It makes so much sense how he responded
to Lav like every right. Uh yo, that's cool. I'm probably going
to buy a Rolls-Royce after this. It's like you just see
Good night, guys. Happy Thanksgiving. I love you. The Jamie that
hooked up with Nick White. It is. It is. Yes, it is. >> Everybody,
thank you all for coming. This program was made possible by contributions
from viewers like